every day six days a week usually around
5:30 in the morning we're here from scar
we do MIT work with your conditioning if
we were training for a fight sometimes
we'll go to UCLA and we'll train through
a Manny Pacquiao train when I'm out of
town if I'm shooting a movie or just on
vacation and I can't get to the gym I
have a whole routine I could do with
just myself in a hotel shadow boxing
jumping rope sit-ups push-ups all that
fun stuff air squats training say this
is the most important piece of equipment
right we have it that bad it goes
forward in hundreds every time you're
going to connect and fight fight oh
probably next 30 40 percent of the time
really so so this emulates the motion
another you can be done with this ball
now it may look easy but with my butt
above my shoulders and just slightly
extending my arms everything from my
hips all the way to the bottom of my
chest is being stretched and tested so
instead of conventional sit-ups do a
bunch of stuff here where my legs
elevated I'll do them on the ground and
move out this puts an incredible strain
so as far as diet is concerned since I
work on a TV show that it's about guys
who diet I do something called the Paleo
diet
nothing post agricultural revolution so
no grains no oats no Rice's basically
meats and anything that we would have
eaten when we were cavemen
you